the Joe Rogan experience are you worried
at all about something like that you
worried about a war with China with do
you think like Russia China like I've
been hearing this term hot war you know
like we're involved in a cold war with
Russia were involved in a cold war with
Russia what it might be a hot war
bullets oh yeah I mean I I don't know if
I can imagine us getting into a war like
that again but I do worry about like
like hacking like more of like a what's
it called soluble yes I / why I think
that's much more likely it is much more
likely but goddamn if there was some
sort of like a real attack from China or
from Russia I would be more China than
Russia I think the what up from what I
understand Russia does not really have
the money they have you know they have a
military but they don't have the kind of
military that we have it's pretty big
drop off from the United States to what
Russia has but they're scary enough and
dangerous enough that we have to keep an
eye on them China ever since nuclear
weapons came about people are like yeah
let's not do those kinds of wars and
yeah we still do them in Iraq we still
did in that past Afghanistan we'll still
go in if there's air quotes insurgents
right yeah and you know we need the oil
yeah a little oh no III were i ho think
about I think often like what if there
was a war and they had to put the draft
back in and then I think about all my
guy friends and I'd be like well first
of all I don't want them to fight like
cuz I like them but also can you imagine
like mark Normand like as a soldier he's
a pretty fit guy he's very fit but I
can't imagine him like killing people
you know like I can't imagine him on a
battlefield he'd be probably make snarky
jokes kill people
I can imagine or kill people I can
imagine re giving the other soldiers
some sort of draw hill
[Laughter]
we definitely dosed their water supply
guys I noticed obtuse find the reservoir
today a lot of fun well who are your
friends you think would be a good
soldier um well I think Dan Soder would
be a good soldier he's a big fella he's
a big guy and he's also just like a
ballplayer
he was a football player I mean he's a
he's the teddy bear but he's also I
think for the right reasons he'd be like
I would kill him but it would have to
feel personal to him personal yeah the
commies I don't think it's more fun to
think about the view I don't think could
do it like like there's no way Keith
Robinson even before his stroke was
getting into a war but after the stroke
maybe he's got less to lose no he's even
now now he'd be like he'd be like I'm
out I got a stroke look at me I can't
walk I can't fight
has he had any recovery of his motor
skills he it's still pretty much like
not super usable yeah but he gets up on
stage every night jokes are probably
funnier than ever his stroke material is
like really really good really yeah Wow
that's awesome yeah and he's he's one of
my favorite people to sit at the table
with because you sit down you're
immediately making fun of each other
right right now you're making fun of
everyone else like it's just jokes the
whole night people don't understand why
that's so fun for us it's to [ __ ] on
each other it's great it's so much fun
it's one of my favorite things to do is
one of my favorite things too about
comics is shout out each other it's fun
and it also it's good for you yes it's
healthy to like get [ __ ] on to you
laughs and like know that you could
laugh you're so people who can't laugh
at someone [ __ ] on them they're the
worst the worst the worst yeah it's just
like we're just having fun I thought so
like it allows us to say this stuff it
like cuz comics will say pretty much
anything on stage but there is a line
where we're like no this is for only
other comments yes we got a yes there's
often times we'll be in a discussion and
we'll kind of look around and be like
I heard any of that stuff we were
talking about having sex with midgets I
don't think any of us are gonna have a
career anymore yeah if someone put like
a hidden camera and a hidden microphone
in the back bar of the Comedy Store oh
Jesus Christ
yeah I mean really really in trouble I'm
trying to shock other comics you know
shock road hardened veterans because our
problem is that like we want to say the
funniest thing yeah and normally that's
way past the line even past our line
where you're just like no this is it
[Applause]